hi guys so i've recently completed the
medium
a homage to the sun hill games and i've
had this nagging urge to talk about it
i know it's been spoken about by many
others there's a lot to speculate
but there's one aspect that i feel has
been slightly overlooked
and that is the use of fixed camera
angles i went into this game pretty much
blind
and i got pretty excited when i realized
that it had brought
fixed camera angles back into a
mainstream
horror survival game see
back in the day fixed camera angles were
the
preferred style for survival horror
games and i got major flashbacks to
being a kid
hiding under the duvet watching my
friends play sun hill and
in the dark because i was too scared to
play this technique was popularized back
in the day because of the hardware
limitations
they allowed for pre-rendered
backgrounds which were cheaper
and looked much better than blocky 3d
environments and stretched
textures let's go find dad it also
paired nicely with the
tank controls of the time so for those
of you who remember
the playstation 1 era where the
controller only had a d-pad allowing you
to go
forwards backwards left and right
independently
meaning that you are unable to move
while rotating like a tank tank controls
so that was back then but where are
fixed camera games now
since the hardware limitations have
lifted and the tank controls got
replaced by
more modern controls using analog sticks
the preferred camera style has evolved
to become third or first person and with
good reason
this allows the player to control with
more agency
because it gives them control over the
camera angle itself
and from this it arguably provides more
player immersion
by allowing the player to view from the
main character's perspective
so is there even a need for fixed camera
angles to return
i mean many would argue no fixed camera
angles
hinder the entire gameplay experience by
removing this agency
and restricting player controls and
ability
so why did the medium a modern and
mainstream
horror game choose to take this approach
and ultimately take a step back in so
many players eyes
see the medium offered a unique game
mechanic called
dual reality this brought back
limitations that swayed them
among other reasons to choose a fixed
camera angle
it allowed the devs the opportunity to
control the camera's position
leaving the player free to soak in its
beautiful environments without the
motion sickness
that comes from having two versions of
that same environment
swaying back and forth but still for me
something was
slightly amiss i wanted to figure out
why i felt like something was amiss
and what that was so
initially i went back to figure out what
makes a good survival horror game
or horror anything inside mr stephen
king
hello this is stephen king's book dance
picable
where in it he explains what he feels
makes a good piece of horror work so i'm
going to just read to you an excerpt
the audience screams as the empty
wheelchair chases the lady
but the real scare has already happened
it comes
as the camera drills on those long
shadowy staircases
as we try to imagine walking up those
stairs towards some as
yet unseen horror waiting to happen
tense atmosphere every horror game is
abundant
with creepy enemies to either defeat or
hide from
but the thrill of this genre isn't
actually about the monster
under the bed it's about the journey
between realizing that a monster could
be under the bed
and plucking up the courage to retreat
from the safety of your duvet
to go and check this is the struggle for
the horror franchise and the frustration
that i personally feel
when i realized that a piece of horror
has veered too far
into action it doesn't mean that you
shouldn't be able to defend yourself
once that monster does finally emerge
from under the bed
but i want to feel like i've been able
to overcome something
to get to that point to simply shoot a
horde of zombies that are just
lined up in a hallway with no build-up
just does not cut it for me
sorry resident evil 5-6
although sex is fun to play with a
friend i will give her that
to create tension you need pacing
a way to slow the player down so they'll
notice every pin drop
and wind howl to heighten their senses
and let them revel within their journey
toward
the monster some horror games do this by
stifling a player's movement speed and
personally i really don't feel like this
works
i feel like it's too intrusive and it
ends up actually just causing
frustration
for a player why did we split up this is
such a bad idea
i'm walking so slow it doesn't make
sense and it takes them out of the
experience which is the opposite
of what you're trying to do here fix
camera angles however
skew the player's vision which innately
makes them want to move
slower in anxious anticipation of what
awaits them
in the next camera view and by
prohibiting their direct
view of what is in front of them this
actually heightens
other senses it leads the player to
become more
perceptive and rely on audio cues or
visual clues
to warn them of an impending danger
actually
a recent example of this is within
little nightmares 2 which i am currently
still in the middle of playing love that
game
this platformer game uses a side on view
for its 2.5 d
effect fixing the camera to move
alongside the player so it's not
technically
a fixed camera game however they do have
a fixed
camera angle so the developers have more
control over that
the game cleverly teases players with
audio and shadows before revealing the
dreaded monster
or they even manage to keep the monster
out of focus as the players play
which leaves all the tiny details to the
player's imagination
which innately is just going to make
anything much more
terrifying giving the player full
control of a camera from a third or
first person perspective
just would never have the same effect
that's normal
narrative not all of us but most of us
need a reason to become frightened
something that touches us more than just
big monsters are scary or character
might
die i'm gonna die again what do i do
here
where do i go what is my purpose in life
so many questions we need a goal to
reach
and a reason to feel invested in the
players survival and if you can sprinkle
a little bit of relatability into the
mix
then the fears become much more intense
as a relationship that you develop with
the character you're controlling
strengthens
and fixed camera angles allow unique
ways to tell narrative through
cinematics
and subtle suggestions oh my gosh that's
really hard to say
subtle subject suggestions
you try and say it see this way of
representing environments mimics that of
a film
developers can use low angles to show a
sense of scale
high angles to create a sense of
repression artistic
semi-fixed transitions like in silent
hills to disorient a player
these are all ways of adding to an
atmosphere that is pivotal
in evoking the intense emotions of fear
and anxiety that are needed within a
horror game
these camera angles can subvert player
expectations
by surprising them by showing the player
through the viewpoint of a monster
just out of sight through a window pane
or a locked
door subtly reminding the player that
they are never truly alone
and to always keep their guard up this
mixture of different camera angles
actually allows the player to survey the
character that they're controlling which
is really rare nowadays
what with third-person over-the-shoulder
camera angles and especially with first
person games
where it's an exciting moment when you
find a mirror
batman the player could visibly see
their character's emotional state after
they're recovering from a recent enemy
encounter
or if they're creeping through a dark
hallway towards the soft sound of
knocking
behind a door from the other end of the
corridor see as humans we
feed off emotion and most of us can't
help but feel empathy
if we see others in pain or in fear
and why is this not used more in games
outside of cut scenes
when i was playing the last of us two i
would stop and go into photo mode and
geez
the character animations that are
amazing and
their emotional states are just
represented so well
in every single scenario that i decided
to pause in it was done
so good but i only noticed that when i
took the time to pause the game and
actually have a look
at what eddie was feeling and yes i know
if you have control over the camera you
can technically just turn the camera so
you can look
front facing at your character but
realistically who is going to do that
while playing the game
not me i want to see what's in front of
me if i have the option i will do that
strategy and puzzle solving so i've
spoken a lot about how we can use
fixed camera angles to bring a cinematic
quality just like we see in horror films
but this
is a game after all so players expect a
level of engagement and difficulty to
overcome to survive
a tense environment the player is
challenged with problems that they have
to solve
this is either in the form of
environmental challenges
outsmarting danger or so they can face
their fear head-on
and overcome it when you have a visual
constraint
almost everything becomes a puzzle even
killing enemies
as you have to constantly stay on guard
as to
where the enemies might be and where the
best places would be
to lure enemies towards to kill them or
where the best places would be
to hide from enemies if you encounter
them that's why especially back in the
day with survival horror games
if you were given the option of combat
to defend yourself then ammunition was
extremely scarce
so conserving that ammunition for boss
battles
was vital and the best players would
instead find windows of opportunity
to avoid combat completely in order to
conserve their ammunition and more
powerful weapons
for tougher enemies that will no doubt
be ruthless and take
a lot of damage
jump scares are a staple of the horror
genre
and if timed correctly and used not too
often they could actually be extremely
effective
fixed camera angles allow the developers
control
over what the players can view allowing
them to switch the camera angle
at just the right time so as to focus on
the climatic event that the quiet
dark hallway has been leading up to as
an arm
crashes through the door fingertips
stretching out
just in front of the player's shocked
face it's too easy
to miss a dramatic event when you're
playing in first person and even
in third person and it's just not the
same when the control
is taken away completely and
everything's put into a cutscene
having the devs lining up the camera
makes it much easier to scare the player
once they finally do come face to face
with the monster
they're forced to witness the jump scare
in all its glory
but also have the burden of the control
over reacting to it
and the events that unfold immediately
afterwards
what's behind the door or larking at the
top of the stairs
is never as frightening as the door or
the staircase itself
and because of this comes the paradox
the artistic work of horror
is almost always a disappointment the
monster
when the player finally does come face
to face with the monster that's been
hunting them throughout the game
nine times out of ten it'll be somewhat
of a relief
as a lot of the fear lies within the
unknown
take amnesia for example that game was
terrifying and it brought back
survival horror when it had started
to veer into a more action genre a lot
of the fear stemmed from the fact that
you had to run away from the monster
so the fear of the unknown was there
throughout
most of the game however once players
started to become a bit braver
and take a good look at the model itself
then they became
accustomed to it and even turned it into
pretty hilarious memes
it's always hard to find that balance
between keeping an element
of unknown while also satisfying the
need to reward the player's bravery
by revealing the horrors and since it's
a video game
giving them a chance to physically
overcome it
which i will also say the medium just
did not give us that chance to do it's
very annoying every
main boss battle just occurred within a
cutscene
and i was so ready so ready and it just
no it's over
anyway fixed camera angles makes
fighting enemies harder
as the player's camera control is taken
away from them
which leads the enemy to become even
more intimidating
this can also be a source of frustration
for the player
especially if the enemy spawns in or
moves towards a place where the camera
angle swaps
or they cannot see properly however it
really can be used
as a tool for the player to have a
chance to confront the monster
without getting a really close look at
every detail i'll refer you back to my
earlier comments
on little nightmares too so some
examples perhaps the player can hear it
just beyond the camera's view
and when they brave walking towards the
camera the monster then walks out in
front of the camera themselves
intimidating the player and still not
allowing them a proper view
of the monster itself this also leads to
interesting enemy concepts
such as monsters which can scale the
walls to keep
out a view of those fixed camera angles
such as
liquors in resident evil and each enemy
type
will have their telltale to help players
know that they're there without the
players needing to control the camera
such as zombies with their constantly
outstretched arms
so that their fingers will poke out
behind corners
duh ah or drips of liquid from the
ceilings
of something waiting to pounce which is
what the liquors do
right pretty sure so i've just talked
your ear off about the positive uses of
fixed camera angles and how they can be
used to enhance a game especially a
survival horror game
so where did the medium fall short with
this their chosen playstyle for
overcoming the monster sections of their
game
was stealth however their level design
really didn't accommodate for this and
fixed camera angles
only hindered it more god it was so it
was so frustrating
there were limited places to hide most
of the time only being
one place and sometimes you even had to
backtrack
and that really isn't intuitive when the
fixed camera angle
is faced towards and past the player
during these stealth moments it was
extremely hard
to get a good view on where the hiding
spots were
in the dark and cluttered environments a
lot of the times
i would move towards what i thought was
a hiding spot
only to get stuck on collision that i
couldn't really
make out in front of me and that really
took me out of the gameplay experience
can i get can i not get behind like any
other [ __ ] cover
tell you what i just absolutely hated
the stealth in that game i really
i feel like there was no options for the
player
um every single time i play a stealth
game i always have
multiple different paths to choose uh
with this game there was none i don't
even think you were supposed to be
choosing it was just very linear
but if you are a player who plays
multiple types of stealth games sorry
just kick the desk
then you probably would have failed at
these stealth
these stealth moments because you're
used to being able to move around
and make your decisions but you couldn't
even see the environment and
most the time when you thought you had
multiple choices you didn't
lol jokes you're caught you're dead
anyway now the camera angles did do a
really good job of
showing the scale of the beautiful
environments and yes
these environments were beautiful it is
a beautiful game
visually very nice to look at but it
really lacked
the flair and the creativity of the old
survival horror games that would use
fixed camera angles it did not shock the
player with unusual camera placements
and it hardly ever switched viewpoints
to hinder the player's view
in such a way that they were edging
forwards with the promise of something
to anticipate
beyond the camera's bounds and the main
boss battles
where the player got to confront the
most intimidating enemies in the game
were all handled in cut scenes i mean
that's more of just an overall
disappointment
than a reflection on the camera decision
but still
the game design just didn't quite match
up with that being said though
i would like to see them give it another
go i mean the dual reality
was a unique take on the genre and i did
really enjoy
seeing two different versions of the
same location being displayed
simultaneously
i even did notice a couple of subtle yet
eerie moments where
i would look through the mirror into the
spirit world and
see a spooky ghost like thing
behind me there and i would have loved
to see more moments like that
that kind of took me off guard a little
bit and like i've said
the game's visuals were breathtaking and
i'm sure that fixed camera angles helped
with that
allowing my eye to wander while playing
without having the camera constantly
move to stick by my character
the establishing shot of some rooms were
enough to make me stop moving completely
just to compare the drastic differences
between the normal world and the spirit
one
as a giant hand reached out towards an
otherwise normal window
any game attempting to bring a unique
mechanic to the genre
is always refreshing to see and
therefore i'm making this video just to
share my opinion in the hopes that more
developers will take risks i'm not a fan
of the technique being patented though
as i would like to see if other studios
could adapt it or build upon it
but oh well i also didn't make this
video to say that fixed camera games are
any better than third or first camera
games
i played many of those that left me
extremely immersed
and terrified however i do believe that
there are certain moments
and atmospheric techniques that are only
achievable by using this pretty much
dead
video game style and that's a shame but
i'd like to know your thoughts
do you agree or disagree with my points
on fixed camera angle games
do let me know in the comments below i'd
love to start a conversation about this
also did you play the medium and did you
have the same opinions on it as me in
regards to the camera angles that they
chose
or not all opinion's valid
let's start a conversation have a lovely
day or evening
and i'll see you in the next video bye
i just want to say i really enjoyed
making this type of video
and i'd love to do more design
commentary
so if you found this useful or helpful
or
interesting in any way please do leave
it a like and let me know
if you want to see more videos like this
cool okay bye
bye